just a few days ago one of the
undisputed kings of twitch xqc was sent
a manila envelope filled with syringes
that he opened on Street now obviously
there is no way to tell what crazy [ __ ]
you're gonna see on Twitch from week to
week but this time this thing was
seriously [ __ ] up
[Music]
so if you've never heard or watched him
scream on the internet xq c is an X
overwatch League Pro who just couldn't
keep his mouth shut
and got booted from the Dallas fuel
since then he has become one of the
biggest streamers in the world I'll be
the first to say that xqc is a little
bit wild welcome to the jungle thanks
for subscribing he broadcasts wealth
organized chaos from grandmaster over
watch play to variety games to IRL
streams to reacting to our content on
the internet it is the full 2020 Summer
package they're also bad like quit the
game this suite these videos are timed
and played for tonight your [ __ ]
trash like many streamers before him
perhaps most notably sodapoppin he set
up a P o box so viewers can send them
gifts to open on Street as you might
imagine this strategy often ends with
some well let's say interesting gifts
but the idea is still there and it's
always funny it's one of the best ways
for streamers to really interact with
their chat what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me right now
I needed pictures of myself but this
time it wasn't all fun and games right
after what looked like a plush owl doll
a can of cat food and an organic bag of
gummy worms xqc picked up an ominous
manila envelope and when he opened it he
was not pleased
these are syringes okay I'm done holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
as you can see despite his usual
anything-goes sort of mentality he was
pissed and seriously who wouldn't be who
the [ __ ] sends something like that he
does what I'm sure any of us would do he
runs and throws it in the garbage
after touching his face and then runs to
the bathroom to wash his hands and when
he returned to the stream he had a
pretty uncharacteristically serious
message to the sender guys it's just
what yeah it's just what they read like
I don't get too much attention but it's
like they were if I [ __ ] did there's
like a bunch of like syringes that are
like Pat kids did I'm sure I'm sure
thank all the boys it's like it yeah I'm
gonna for Terry kidding me then it
became pretty clear that he was
seriously shocked by this I mean
normally xqc would just laugh something
like this off but he asked his chat for
some advice to calm him down which is
that this guy would get it I fasted but
he's opened it right like very carefully
well nothing could happen right [ __ ]
to the hearts my heart's racing did you
seriously know you've crossed a line
when you tilt xqc like that I honestly
don't think I've ever seen him get like
that on stream you don't do [ __ ] like
that that she can be like
life-threatening that's that's not
that's not funny it's not even like half
funny live in a little bit
now look obviously this isn't the first
time someone's gotten something crazy in
the mail on street remember when
pokeyman got that full-length pillow
with her photo on either side
it's a body pillows me or that time she
was literally gifted a stun gun and then
there's the king of the mail day himself
sodapoppin who was gifted a life-size
sex doll which has become a fixture in
the background of his stream yes it's a
sex doll yes I was hoping so can I hold
her hand nice now to me the appeal to
the addition of this stuff to the
streaming world is pretty obvious its
raw and all the opening of these
packages happens right on stream which
allows twitch chat to shock or gross out
their favorite streamers it is
legitimately a twitch chat members join
in any form of entertainment you can
obviously see why you would gravitate
towards this kind of thing if you were a
viewer it makes you feel special in the
way that a shout-out or an emote never
can but in the case of ecstasy here you
can obviously see the downside setting
up Pio boxes is not new like I said but
you have to feel like there's kind of
this gross game of one-upping each other
where you have to see what the next
crazy thing you can send to a streamers
the fact is streamers are incentivized
to do this because twitch chat loves and
if you're on twitch is side how are you
gonna police this you can't just like
ban opening gifts and that's before we
even talk about subjects like daxing and
swatting which have been going on on
Twitch for years
this is video when the two were
confronted by police officers by the
time I was holding my hands up I was
gonna make a move you know I was gonna
turn my stream off with one hand you
know I was a little nervous I mean dude
you got guys pointing rifles it they
weren't pistol Yeah right now obviously
at the simplest level
this stuff is all meant to be fun and
games even I love watching xqc opening
these strange objects and trying to
figure out what would possess a fan to
send something like that look what
happened to X you see in this situation
was obviously [ __ ] up but I think
we've established that people love
watching their favorite streamers open
gifts the
problem is when it goes too far and
there's absolutely nothing to stop
someone from sending them literal [ __ ]
there's another thing it's you know what
I think there's big problem with
shipping you know like no no no
yeah shipping like packages I don't have
a board